as the next phase of bricks it gets
underway it appears that the UK and the
EU start by agreeing that they share one
of the biggest goals leather side what
to have to pay customs duties to trade
goods tariffs would hurt if there's no
trade deal now EU exporters would face
12 billion pounds of duties on goods
coming into the UK while UK exporters to
the EU would face costs of 5.2 billion
pounds much of this likely to be passed
on to consumers but there's a hitch the
EU said in the document this morning
that to get a zero tariff deal it wants
a level playing field to stop Britain
posing too much of a competitive threat
from their doorstep Boris Johnson has
said no to anything that means following
EU rules that's because of this sets out
in today's government statement the
ambition of restoring a relationship of
sovereign equals otherwise known as
taking back control this would see
Britain being able to do things
differently to the EU in areas like
workers rights in the environment rather
than relying on European courts to
enforce common rules but this has even
more consequences with the EU listing
areas like science and innovation and
youth culture and education development
and international cooperation and so on
that won't take place if the UK doesn't
change its red lines and it ignores that
Britain's already agreed to place some
European rules in areas like citizens
rights
fast forward to 2035 in government
economists suggest Boris Johnson's type
of brexit deal will have knocked 6% of
GDP compared to staying in the EU that's
a bigger drop than Teresa Mays brexit
deal and about the same scale of losses
even the financial crisis a decade ago
Boris Johnson says this is all worth it
say Britain could rear major after
decades of hibernation inside the EU
chrysalis the negotiation will determine
what this looks like in practice